you can't break the law and just forgive  everyone's student loan debt it just  doesn't work that way right the  democrats are the party where you don't  have to pay back loans and then we find  out that the marjorie taylor green and  husband business taylor commercial  received a loan for a hundred and eighty  two thousand dollars  and they had a hundred and eighty three  thousand dollars forgiven why is the  amount forgiven more than the loan  amount well they also had accrued  interest forgiven isn't that nice that  loan was reportedly for employee wages  of course as with any of the there's so  much ppp fraud the irs is investigating  generally we don't have any reason to  believe they're specifically  investigating the marjorie taylor green  loan but how much of that money  in theory for employee wages actually  went to marjory taylor green's employees  that's a very very good question